sur en dialyse bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin alors
pas de grande surprise a donc puisque le
nom d'amy koné woerth avait déjà fuité
dans la presse
est ce que le choix justement de cette
figure de la droite religieuse
elle s'inscrit dans la stratégie de
campagne de donald g selon vous
naturellement ça s'inscrit parce que il
fait le même pari qui en 2016
il a fait des promesses à sa base
électorale conservatrice qu'il allait
nommer des juges conservateurs
donc il répète et respecte ses
engagements vis-à-vis de sa base
électorale
il faut préciser que ça c'est un aussi
un choix électoral stratégique de la
part de monsieur dans notre ombre parce
que il faut souligner qu' un tiers de
républicains sont faveur de l'avortement
et il y aura 7 % des électeurs
indépendante qui sont indécis
donc eux ils peuvent faire pencher aussi
la votent en faveur d'un candidat ou
d'un autre donc il a fait le choix
ça l'a fait élire président qui espère
pour sa réélection que ça va marcher
mais l'entente du service a pu
galvaniser les supporteurs de by then
they leur côté mais je pense qu'ils y
suit sa stratégie qu'il a fait en 2016
alors jusqu'à maintenant on ne connaît
pas la date du vote de confirmation
puisque le sénat doit se prononcer
donald trump est vrai que le sénat
justement se prononce avant les
élections
du 3 novembre joe biden non évidemment
pourquoi c'est si crucial cette date
concernant le vote de confirmation j'ai
quoi que les échanges houleux entre les
démocrates et de républicains s'il
s'agit de savoir s'ils vont placer au
nom un juge conservateur hossein de la
cour suprême
bien entendu c'est le droit du président
dé nommer un nouveau juge à la cour
suprême
vous devez savoir je vous rappelle si
elle madame bavette a été déjà englobé
par le sénat en qualité des magistrats
auprès de la cour d'appel
donc c'est très intéressant de savoir
quelles étaient les vôtres parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ne préside on parle pas
il y avait plusieurs démocrates trois
sénateurs démocrates ont voté en faveur
de madame barrette
lors de sa nomination 2017 donc si tu es
invité d'honneur probation conformation
sénatoriales part à huit partisans
même quand il appelle majorité en faveur
des républicains il va plusieurs
démocrates confrontation faveur bien
entendu il espère vous savez aussi le
démocrate ont d'autres moyens pour
contrer cette tendance conservatrice
auprès de la cour suprême
s'ils souhaitent selon la constitution
si par hasard monsieur by des mois je
pense pas comme je l'aï dit à plusieurs
fois son hypothèque
il sera élu mais dans l'hypothèse
d'imaginer que monsieur baldé
l'intérieur il peut moduler les normes d
des magistrats au sein de la cour
suprême
ils peuvent augmenter les normes donc
nommé deux nouveaux magistrats diluer
les normes des consommateurs à la cour
suprême donc il ya d'autres stratégies
par la suite et c'est pas la dernière
chose ça a été fait dans l'histoire ça
paie présentant à qu'il ya neuf
magistrats mais aux eaux pendant le 19e
siècle qui avaient des noms différents
donc ce n'est pas un un cadre
exceptionnel ça existait auparavant et
ça peut arriver
compte tenu des différences
profond entre les démocrates et
républicains la dernière question
monsieur yan aux comment cette
nomination a été perçu par les
américains est ce que ils craignent un
recul des droits des femmes en passant
justement par une juge féministe affirmé
à une juge qui au contraire est
ouvertement contre l'avortement
c'est une très bonne question
j'ai eu récemment j'ai écrit un article
à ce sujet il y avait des recherches par
des des recherches sur la question ils
ont analysé presque 80 ans de
jurisprudence et avec le temps la
journée les la cour suprême et ces
magistrats sont des garants d'une
stabilité jurisprudentielle et qu'est ce
qu'on va malgré les côté conservateur
malgré leur appartenance à un certain
religion on voit que la jurisprudence
évolué très modérément et très lentement
et ils sont garants de cette stabilité
jose prudentielles les magistrats donc
moi je fais confiance à ces magistrats l
institution et qui on voit il existe
cette pérennité jeu résidence à dans
l'institution il va faire confiance on a
aidé deux cent cinquante ans et qui il a
résumé des problèmes très graves qui ont
calé auquel il devait faire face
donc je pense qu'on peut faire confiance
à la cour suprême et je crois pas qu'il
y aura des grands changements ils
peuvent avoir des petites modifications
mais pas de grands changements
merci beaucoup rendez à l'autre d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat et président de
république en 26 ans